- Today we're gonna talk about
the two keys to getting A's in law school
and why most students miss
the single most important
opportunity that they have.
(soft instrumental music)
So if you're a law student,
you think you're in law school,
but actually you're in essay school.
That's because almost
all of your final grades
will be based on
issue-spotting-exam essays.
So what are the things that you need to do
in order to ace your
issue-spotting-essay exams?
Well I think there are two
things that you should do.
The first thing is, the
one that everyone does,
it's the most obvious thing
that you can do in law school
and that's master the law.
Everybody knows this,
if you go to law school
you have to master the law.
If you go into a contracts class
you need to master the law of contracts.
If you go into a property class
you need to master the law of property.
Learning the substantive
law is the table-stakes
in law school, it's
necessary but not sufficient.
And to most people's surprise,
the person who knows the most law
is not necessarily the person
that's going to get the
best grade on the exam.
In fact, far from it.
The person who studies the hardest
and works the hardest is not necessarily
the person that's going
to get the best grade.
In fact they almost never do.
Everyone is going to
have to learn the law,
but learning the law itself is not enough.
That'll get you through the door,
but that won't get you an A on the exam.
The second thing that you have to do
in order to ace you law school exam
is the thing that so few people do.
And that's that you
have to master the test.
In other words you have to learn
how to write a good law school essay.
Learning how to take a
law-school-essay exam
is not a dark art.
There is a science to it.
It's a skill.
And any skill can be learned over time,
just like learning the
piano or playing guitar.
You'll get better the more you do it
and there are strategies
that will allow you
to learn how to do it faster.
The worst thing that you can
possibly do in law school
is to never take a practice test
until the day of your first final exam.
Now first, let me issue a disclaimer,
many people say that it is impossible
to improve your skills on
a law school final exam.
Now to those people I say good luck.
It's so odd to me that the same people
that spent $2,000 on an LSAT prep-course
and learned how to take the LSAT,
turn around and say that it's impossible
to get better at law school exams.
There are so many people, myself included,
who learned the strategies for logic games
and reading comprehension on the LSAT
and improved their LSAT
scores dramatically.
And it's the same in law school.
Personally I would take the person
who has practiced the hell
out of issue-spotting exams
over the person who
has memorized every law
in contracts or torts or property.
And the hidden benefit of
learning the strategies
of how to take a law-school-essay exam
is that it shapes the way that you study
throughout the entire semester.
You study the right things,
the things that are
going to be on the test.
Because you get a feeling
for what can be tested
and it's strange but not
everything you learn in class
can be tested.
For example issue-spotting exams
tend to test causes of
actions in lawsuits.
So they're not well suited for
testing the philosophy of law
or questions of policy.
Then plus you learn the law better
through application.
If you had enough practice tests
you could conceivably
learn the entire class
through the answers to those tests
without actually having to study.
Believe me, once you miss a
question on a practice test
you're not likely to
miss that question again,
when you see it on the next test
and maybe that next
test is your final exam.
So that raises the question,
why don't more people do this?
Why do so many people
focus on the law only
and miss out on the second
key to acing their exam?
Well most people think law school essays
are just like undergrad essays.
If you put off taking practice exams
and at least looking at
a sample law school exam
you might not even know
that a law school exam
is very, very different
from an undergrad essay.
And if you don't know that it's different
you might not even know
that it's a skill that is
worth honing over time.
And of course let's not forget
that there is so much information
about the substantive
law that you're learning.
Every semester you're probably
in three core classes.
And each one of those
classes is teaching things
that you've never heard before.
So there's always more time to study
the law itself and it is far too easy
to just put off practice tests
and put off learning
the strategies of essays
until much, much later in the semester.
For a lot of people perfect
is the enemy of good
and they keep trying to get perfect
at knowing the substantive law
without even trying to learn
the basics of writing
issue-spotting exams.
As a result they never
learn how to spot the issues
and they never learn how
to write those good essays,
the ones that will get A's on the exam.
But don't be like those other students.
Know that there are two keys
to getting A's on your final exam.
One is of course learning
the substantive law,
but the other is learning
to master the test itself.
In another video we'll explain the tactics
for how you can start
taking practice exams
months before the finals
and the strategies
that going into spotting issues
and writing those A-worthy exams.
So if you liked this video,
please click Like and Subscribe.
For more law school crushing tips
and also don't forget to
download the free checklist below
that'll help you crush your exams.
Thanks for stopping by.
(upbeat instrumental music)